[Music]
we want to show you I'm very very
excited being here and show you how we
can make together Salesforce and Google
cloud customer engagement platform first
of all just to move a little bit can I
ask you to yes raise your hands who of
you are in the business area hope you
make the business decisions in your
companies okay cool
who of you are developers the guys that
actually really make the decisions
go who view do you use Salesforce in
your company hey that's a very good and
who you is right now doing our planning
and do some kind of IOT project amazing
this is your session actually this is
your session there are during the in the
right place we are what I want you guys
to understand here today are three main
things one is that we are going to help
you bring value from the data you're
getting from IOT which is very very
important the second one is that we are
bringing together our IOT blending our
IOT knowledge on Google cloud on how to
secure communication how to scale how to
get insights from that data with the 360
view of the customer that surface can
give you and the last one is that we are
here for you we have done it before and
we can help you do it this is this is
real so now this wouldn't be a real IOT
session if I would not start with a huge
number it has to be like that eight
point four billion of devices government
says were connected to the Internet
IOT devices were in 2017 it's important
they the growth that we had the 36%
growth between 2016 and 2017 is
incredible and this number of devices
that are going up is just getting faster
and faster as you know 20 billion by
2020
garner says that we're going to have now
these devices what are doing is
generating data and we are generating
data faster and faster and faster just a
single engine from a plane has more than
5,000 sensors is generating 10 gigabytes
of data per second if we add all of that
for a whole day and I won't I don't know
you but I won't go on a plane that has
only one engine that is more information
on a single plane running to fly in 12
hours that the amount of data that we
get Google on social media in 2016
the machines are generating an amazing
amount of data so what that's the main
thing when a customer calls me and say I
want to connect my devices IOT is pretty
cool
I say why and this is the main question
this is how do I use a IOT to make it
useful for the business how could I get
value from that data this what all of us
should be here and this is the important
thing every single time I visit one of
my customers I tell them why and if they
can answer and they have a very good
value for that then I go ahead I just
realized that I haven't introduced
myself my name is Roberto Guerrero as
you have heard I'm Spanish so I'm just
realizing that if you take a Spaniard to
give a speech in less than 50 minutes
you get someone respects very very fast
so stop me there raise your hand my job
in Google I mean IOT especially is
covering Europe Middle East and Africa
and my job is not to sell IOT which is
great is to make you make my customers
get the best solution created try ot
so this is this is what I do this is
what I do I try to to make my customers
understand that is not about connecting
devices connecting device and IOT the
announcement we heard from England this
morning it's just a way to get
information in the cloud
what I do with that is what really
matters
so I have the data I start doing things
and many of my customers tell me well we
have heard about IOT for a few years now
and we are already there we have
invested in connecting my products
connecting my car connecting my machines
on on my on my manufacturing plant I am
connecting my lights and in the end what
we have or what they have is silos
solutions that are siloed on IOT but IOT
is evolving my customers the ones are
more advanced or hopefully if you start
working with us today I'm gonna tell you
you have to have a different idea
different strategy on IOT you need to
find an end to a solution thinking what
I want to do I'm starting from the
device until the end go on a single
platform
that is going to give you the tools and
the solutions to get the value and they
intend they if the intelligence from
from that data so very quickly I'm going
to show you what we usually do and it's
very important because there are two or
three points here that you will see what
I am talking about first we have to
start with the business case we have to
start with what why join the data okay
then we have the devices that we need to
connect in a secure way then we have the
cloud solution well it's going to give
you the scalability it's going to give
you the security it's gonna give you the
tools to may not happen then your
company probably is going to build an
application on top of that and you are
going to connect that to CRM probably
Salesforce ERP and other solutions then
comes what is important for you which is
what information is gonna get that is
going to transform your business and
finally you're gonna have a product that
was static and now it's a 24/7 product
it's a pro that is life and you have to
be support to your customers we have
begun here with the business case
probably to do something with your
customers we are going in the middle
with the business system connecting to
CRM which is about your customers
we an giving support to your customers
you see the trend here IOT and your
customer and as Marc Benioff the CEO of
Center says behind every device there is
a customer is what you should have in
mind when you look for one of these
solutions so how do we do it at Google
we have three legs here we have the
technology and this is what next is all
about do you have heard what is and is
not only about IOT core it's about all
the different solutions that we have
around it then we have this
participating team of people that can
help you do that and then last but not
least we have our amazing partners and I
am excited to have you here as self we
surfers today because this is one of the
best policies that we have on a IOT I
touch something over here this just to
show you that this is life exactly
there we go now finally if we have if we
see from the first leg the technology
IOT core is the starting point it's just
the gateway it's just the way that we
bring data in a secure way and a
scalable way and managing the devices
into the cloud but then you have all of
the rest of the solutions as we will see
later in the demo that can make that
happen and make that give you that value
that we are looking for and on a third
leg we have our partners and to see what
searchers can bring us to this solution
I'm very pleased to introduce Neil to
Lisa Alessandro senior director IOT and
platform strategy partnerships from
Salesforce
Kehaar applause
so this is the way there we go so what
can you do with Salesforce IOT so I'd
like to tell you ladies and gentlemen we
are on the brink of a technological
revolution that will fundamentally alter
the way that we live and work and
interact with one another so the fourth
Industrial Revolution this is the
revolution I'm talking about but let's
think back to previous industrial
revolutions for example in the 1700s
there was steam in the 1800's there was
electricity in the 1900s there is
computing what you're all doing now
looking at your phones instead of
listening to me that's okay
but now we're on the brink of this
fourth Industrial Revolution and what
does that mean what is that what kind of
technologies does that introduce right
so let's think about how previously it
was very linear in terms of how we move
forward but now it's exponential right
and so with AI with machine learning
with robotics with 3d printing these are
all things that are really contributing
to the fourth Industrial Revolution and
you need to think about how are you
going to adopt these technologies in
order to move forward to move your
business forward and one of these
technologies is IOT so let's talk a
little bit about IOT so as Roberto
mentioned your customers are more
connected than ever
behind every customer there is a device
behind every device there is a customer
and so these are devices that are always
on they're very smart they are powered
by AI and they they have they transact
in real time and you need to be able to
transact in real time as well with your
customers and there's a gap right so
there's a gap right now between what
customers expect and how we do customer
service nowadays and what you guys need
to figure out is how do you bridge that
gap and one of the ways that you can
bridge that gap is with IOT because 80%
of b2b customers expect that you
transact with them in real time right so
are you doing that right now have you
thought about how are you gonna harness
the power of the fourth Industrial
Revolution how are you gonna harness AI
and IOT to drive your business forward
so Salesforce IOT can help you unlock
the potential of your connected products
right so you can get IOT data from your
devices to help you and your customers
exceed their expectations so we've got
connected things right and we hook that
up to the Google cloud I owe to platform
they take that data they do some
transformation they may do some other
things with it in terms of the other
products and services that they have and
they send that to Salesforce IOT what
does Salesforce IOT do is it takes that
device data and it enriches it with all
the rich contextual data that you
already have in Salesforce because many
of you said your Salesforce customers so
you can leverage your current investment
in Salesforce add on IOT and voila you
can trigger some sort of an action a
customer engagement in Salesforce so
what might that look like so for example
let's talk about my SmartWatch here
right so when I look at my SmartWatch I
know how many miles I've gone today how
many miles I want to go right how many
more I have to go and whether or not I'm
winning the competition with my neighbor
in terms of doing more miles than he or
she but I can tell you right now if my
watch isn't giving me the information
that I need what am I gonna do I'm gonna
go to one of my competitors I'm gonna
get their watch and that's what you need
to think about if you're not adopting an
IOT strategy that works your competitors
are going to take your business so what
can Salesforce IOT do we can build
amazing customer experiences right so
for example low code no code declarative
platform which basically means that you
can enact an IOT strategy in a matter of
days a matter of weeks not months or
years this is immediate right as a
business user you can do this another
thing is that we've integrated our IOT
with the rest of our CRM platform so you
can rich your IOT with all of the data
from service cloud in sales cloud and in
a
other information that you have in CRM
in finally proactive customer engagement
I mean that's what we're really talking
about right we don't want to be reactive
nowadays we don't want to think oh I
wonder what my customer needs we want to
proactively engage with them through
this int platform so let's talk a little
bit about how we work and how we
complement the Google cloud platform so
basically as we said before we get the
device from these things I mean the data
from these things and we put it into the
Google cloud platform
and then we send it to Salesforce IOT
and what we do there is we create a
profile and that profile is IOT data as
well as contextual data that we get from
Salesforce right and then we create what
we call an orchestration which is
basically a bunch of business rules that
we apply to these profiles and we
trigger again some sort of proactive
customer engagement that could be in
sales cloud service cloud or marketing
cloud and one of the other things that
you need to consider is what other data
might you need what other data might you
want to pull in so you might want to
pull in third-party data for example
weather data you might want to pull in
Google Maps data and just to give a
quick example of how this might work
let's say it's a very warm day and you
have a coca-cola cooler in your office
and you want to get to your office and
get an ice cold coke out but you know
since it's really warm out there's
probably not going to be a lot of coke
left in there when you get there well
coca-cola also knows that it's warm day
out because they have an IOT platform
and they're saying oh okay
you know what we've got our third-party
data from the weather service we know
it's going to be really warm out ok and
we can look inside of Salesforce and we
can see where our coolers are and we can
see that we have a field service guy who
can actually go out and actually
dispatch some more coke to proactively
to that location so that when you get to
the office you can have your nice cold
coke that's an example kind of how IOT
can work so hopefully if you have any
other questions around Salesforce IOT
all stick around you can ask us
afterwards I'd now like to introduce my
colleague Aubrey wing who is actually
going to talk about and provide a demo
how this is really gonna work as well
with the refrigerator thank you for
doing that
what I wanted to do was just give you a
high-level overview and make sure that
you're driving business value so
ultimately what we're going to take a
look at is how you can apply IOT to
answer some really some really exciting
business questions and so what I wanted
to do is start by introducing our use
case and then we'll go into the
different pieces here all right it is a
demo you guys are note you can see that
this is in fact live and alright so our
use case here is based upon logistics
it's a pharmaceutical use case where
really the underlying driver is to go
ahead and ensure product quality and
product quality comes across three
primary dimensions first and foremost I
want to make sure I have the right level
of stock in the places that it's needed
the most
so think of this as do I have the right
stock level in New York or London or San
Francisco the second aspect of this are
the assets that I own to make sure that
the product is is within spec so think
of this is all the refrigerated boxcars
or all the airplanes that we use to make
sure that we're moving product from
place to place and the third is
especially in high-value products or
anything that has a determine spec that
we want to go ahead and say that we're
keeping that
as it should be so in this case we're
monitoring environmental right
temperature the right humidity the right
pressure whatever it may be so put it
simply is my product at the right places
at the right quality and my keeping
track of cold chain custody right bunch
of different use cases all driving
towards a singular business experience
now historically what has happened is
that's three separate that's three
separate logic sets you'll have to join
them and and then test them so that's
months and months and months and with
Google and Salesforce we can go ahead
and get something like that working and
the matter of you know weeks not months
and in fact the business analysts can go
ahead and build that so just to
highlight real quick what we're looking
at its Salesforce IOT here but then
we're gonna work backwards and see how
these two work together so I mentioned
earlier if you look in the upper left
hand corner you see a warning around
geolocation or a geo boundary the second
we're gonna see here is our evaluation
of the equipment is in fact the
equipment is the door jammed is it
operating as a pulling high-voltage and
the last is actually temperature and to
represent this this wouldn't be an IOT
demo if we didn't in fact have Hardware
here so you can see this run live we
have a refrigerator representing the
cold chain we have a sensor pack in here
that's going to give us live readings
and so to best highlight that I'm
actually going to turn the stage back to
Roberto who will take you through the
Google site
thank you can we just go back for a
second to this lights because I would
like to show you what is the
architecture that we are we are seeing
here so we have in fact being an IOT
demos obviously our fridge inside there
is let me show you we have our sensors
running here happily as you can see it's
blinking its life I have temperature
humidity pressure I have many many many
sensors embedded here on these on this
race
so yes make sure that the chain is work
correctly this raspberry this sensors
are something actually are using out
using the Wi-Fi finger
first the data - to the cloud of course
we have at the very front IOT core IOT
college given me the security is giving
me this the device management is giving
me the scalability to bring this data
into the cloud
IATA code is glued to pops up up pops up
is our queuing system is kind of like
the way that I can get information and
make sure that is telemetry data it not
lost it's not lost if I have suddenly a
burst of a virus coming in and then pops
up is also at the same time the way that
I can plug in the different different
pieces of the of the solution that we
give you Google cloud platform if I go
southbound for example we have a data
flow probably I will have different
sensors from the track that is
transporting these these vaccines and I
have information about what it is from
the GPS and I have information from the
temperature and so on I have to make
sure that all that information is put
together in real time and this is what
data flow is gonna is going to help you
to do in real time you can transform the
way that you can massage that data to
make sure is in the format and
complement that data to make sure that
you have everything that you need and
then I'm going to store the data
somewhere here in this example we're
using bigquery our you have heard a lot
about Vic where right now our data
warehouse solution but depending on your
use case we we can suggest which is the
best resolution for you from there
what I am doing is just gathering this
data so I can show you in real time how
how it how it is how it is showing if I
go northbound like I have 12 functions
which is just a small piece of code that
is actually it's actually triggered by
something in this case the telemetry
that comes from the sensors and that is
going to make the solution and inject
that data into Salesforce and nobody
will show you a bit more about that so
let me just go back to the to the demo
now that you have seen the main
architecture just to make sure that you
see that this is actually in real time
this is the old information that is that
is coming in and for those of you that
would like to see a bit more under the
hood what this is about this is the
but from console and happier we said IOT
core is the first step
IOT core I have different registries
here I have very three which is just how
I group the devices and as you will see
these registry has some devices in this
case I have three fridges here I have
the one race in San Francisco that is
communicating and I can see all the
telemetry data when it happens if I dig
down a little bit I can show you for
example how I connect iot-cloud I said I
talked about security a device you'd not
have is not a person a student have an
username and a password for us a device
will have its own private key that is
only know by the device I will use the
private that private key to sign tokens
to talk with us I gotta call will then
check the party publicly just matches
the token that the services the device
has sent to us so I'm sure that the
device is exactly who is as it is and
from now on that information that
elementary data is coming encrypted into
IOT core the next step from IOT core is
pops up that is just how it how it
boring I can show you here that this
registry is animal telemetry data to
this pub subtopic this queuing system
and if you remember the next step is
data flow what I am doing this real-time
transformation of the of the data I have
one here that is doing something very
very simple for the demo purposes of
this is just within the telemetry data
that comes from pops up the raspberry is
actually sending the data in JSON format
and I want the data to be injected in
bigquery so I am transforming that into
equal format and then injecting it into
bigquery and the last step is store that
data so here I have my latest or in
bigquery with all the data from the
fridge and I'm going to actually just
query the table so you see that this is
come in life so I want to see everything
from this data set and I'm gonna order
it by the timestamp
for those of you that use Salesforce and
the scanners Corsi you know what this is
coming from descending I run the query
and you will see that at 2059 UTC I am
receiving telemetry data that actually
twenty point six to twenty 2.63
corresponds to the live data I'm getting
for there so this is the you remember
this is a southbound I am getting this
data and I am going to analyze that data
and I can I can do something meaningful
with it
the last piece if you remember if I go
northbound I have a cloud function but
it's being triggered every single time
so every 3 seconds when this going to
say the raspberry is enemy data every
three seconds I have I have this
function that is kicking in and I can
show you that what is doing is actually
connecting to Salesforce everything is
finishing with status ok so Aubrey if
you want to show us what happens after
this
if you Roberto and now I think that the
the best thing to and to think about
from the next step is that as the
northbound the northbound lanes starts
sending data this is our bi-directional
ability to communicate back and forth
with GCP you're seeing the information
here directly from our fridge and our
raspberry pie I give you a quick view
just a minute ago on what it looks like
in terms of Salesforce and again in
Salesforce our our mission is to make
IOT really accessible we're taking in
this case a state machine which can be a
very you know very powerful and
sophisticated thing that we can offer to
the business users to to to make it
accessible and solve real-world business
problems so I mentioned earlier the
different states as we go through from
normal to warning across the different
use cases all the way to to fault what
happens at that point is that we're able
to take action so you think about Google
as anomaly detection a lot of data the
ability to go ahead and manage security
to go ahead and manage did moving back
and forth provide data services which
Salesforce will allow you to do is take
the anomaly detection and turn that into
response so the response is the last
mile where we have that customer behind
the scenes so what I'm gonna do here is
I'm actually gonna reach over and change
one of the parameters you'll see it
change on both the Google as well as the
Salesforce side so if we go if we go
ahead and take a look at the hardware
real quick
alright folks in the front row here but
certainly we can go ahead and show you
later on I'm going to increase one of
the environmental is the temperature the
humidity I'm gonna be very fancy here
just to do this manually oh that is egg
it will keep we'll keep working on this
and what you're gonna see as soon as it
gets the reading is that we're going to
go ahead and change stage oh there it is
okay so we now have a temperature
warning I keep going I feel like I'm
blowing up balloon animals at a birthday
party all right
and the reason why we do this when you
introduce States is that with IOT you're
gonna continue get a continuous flow of
data where you do not want to
necessarily respond to the first event
there we go all right we have our case
we don't necessarily want to respond to
the first event so let's say for example
my business logic was around stimulus
response which is a really common way to
look at this I get a reading I open a
case I get a reading I actually send
let's say field dispatch but I'm getting
a reading at the rate of once per second
so I'm gonna get 60 cases or 60 dispatch
notices in a minute if I'm not more
sophisticated with this so what we're
doing here
as Lisa mentioned earlier is that we're
contextualizing you have our fridge data
coming in off the left hand side it's an
example of the streaming live event day
that we're getting from a DCP we're
adding the asset data really important
elements one was this in-service does it
have a warranty all right what should we
be doing so what I'm going to show you
here is all the logic that sits behind
the scenes of the states that you just
saw now a little bit of an eye chart
again happy to go over this with you in
more detail either after the session or
I'm going to encourage you to go to
either the GCP IOT or the Salesforce
booths downstairs love to dig into this
stuff but bottom line is you can without
having to program get access to very
sophisticated functionality we can go
back and say what are our targets how
long do you want to wait one of the keys
here is that when I had a fault I'm
going to check for a warranty and the
reason why I do that is because I'm
going to behave different depending on
the contextual information contained
within Salesforce the customer has a
warranty I hope in a case I dispatch
that we automatically are automatically
entitled to service rights if they don't
have a warranty we open an opportunity
to sell them a warranty or perhaps sell
them their replacement parts right if
you're in a marketing campaign perhaps
we're gonna alter the marketing one
event will change the entire
relationship a customer can have with
the brand across multiple functions so I
do want to highlight that as one of the
key things that we bring to the table
what does a case look like in this case
this is the asset sales force IOT
requested a response independent you can
start automating these key business
processes and determining what your
ideal customer experience should be and
ultimately we're able to see IOT
information directly inside CRM or
Salesforce now if you go and you look at
the entire architecture wire all here
why are we here the physical things in
IOT have a digital voice that digital
voice is what your customers want to
tell you use the data to listen to the
customers use sales use GCP to process
and gain insight to be able to manage
the identity use Salesforce to be able
to connect to your customer directly
that being said I believe we've resolved
our problem oh there it is so we're back
to normal
I think they threw it back in the fridge
but if you guys want to manually change
this you're absolutely welcome to and
again as this as we think about the
possibilities of the use case this is
where I get very excited the key
takeaway here is that IOT architecture
improving end to end is something that's
well traveled we know the different
pieces we know the hardware we know the
services the cloud services we know it
different elements can be brought
together and the creativity of the use
case is really where things come
together and actually what I do want to
mention is one of the highlights that
Roberto started off our discussion with
is around the power of the ecosystem
obviously you're seeing GCP and
Salesforce together here but I do want
to highlight the services component we
did a lot of our use case prototyping
and in fact a lot of the work that was
done here on the demo it was with a
partner service partner of ours Dave
Stanton repair it was in the front front
row and I do want to give you a shout
out and thank you for all the input
especially things like the warranty
right how do you manage that separately
what would you do different in terms of
the logic right this is where having the
experience of what the customers are
really looking for helps bring real
business value
the other thing I do want to highlight
yeah if we go back to the slides
all right Salesforce and Google Google
and Salesforce we have a joint customer
that is using proactive using our IOT to
provide proactive proactive service
Rauch clean tech is a great example of
the business value you can bring to the
table what Roush clean tech is doing is
they're monitoring fleet for service
proactively making sure that service
service vehicles school buses are on the
road and that they're they're working
assets so if you think about the
customer experience that sits behind the
business case I want to make sure that a
school bus where a fleet vehicle is on
the road and working and the way we're
gonna do this then we're going to get
check engines like we're gonna get me I
engine telemetry but more than that
we're going to be able to analyze this
for proactive service how do I take that
vehicle and bring it in for service
before there's actually a problem quick
example here of what they're doing and
if you start you can see how
architectural OU's brought a lot of
these different pieces together and
continue to add great use cases geofence
monitoring how do I go ahead and get
this to the nearest service Depot not
just a service Depot how do I have
proactive Diagnostics around fuel
systems the predictive service again
keeping these things working so with
that what I'd like to do is introduce :
Mara who will bring us home
thanks Aubrey thanks very I'm gonna kind
of wrap things up or help if there's one
thing you can leave with today from this
session would be that together together
this between Google and Salesforce will
really complement each other we talked
about how from the physical end device
connecting that to Google cloud out tea
encore getting that data be able to
manage those devices securely push out
updates manage the users that are
involved and then get it into the
traditional Google product sets GCP
products extra machine learning bigquery
all those types of things and then where
you really need to have the action take
place in your business systems and CRM
the deleting leading player out there a
Salesforce get that data into Salesforce
where actions can really take place and
you can really enhance your experience
your customers experience together so
the idea here is you've got best to
breed products here between Google world
class google Salesforce together will
help you streamline this process your
journey your IOT journey make it easier
for you to really see the value and get
the benefits from that all right so
before we wrap up here one of the things
that we'll want you all to know about
you know what you can do after this
you've seen a little bit of the demo you
can attend as a few more IOT breakout
sessions that are going on at the show
check out the IOT showcase on the show
florrum us county south there's an IOT
solution sections that google has
they're showing some other virtual demos
that are going on you can get a free
ice-cream over at the maps or we're
pulling in a number of the different
Google products and capabilities within
IOT and you'll be able to see that on
display ask questions etc there's also
the Salesforce booth which will have a
version of this and you can kick around
the refrigerator and play around it ask
questions go a little bit deeper on the
technology if you're interested in that
and if you need to get a contact with
we've got a site you can go down to
visit as well as you've got any kind of
potential opportunity here that you want
to talk a little bit further you can
reach out to me : merit google.com
available to engage and kind of
quarterback the GCP team and the
Salesforce team together to help you
kind of uncover your your requirements
and needs and guide you through that
journey
[Music]